mettre en lien les étudiants avec les
centres de formation et les entreprises
c'était l'objectif de la première
édition du forum départemental de
l'apprentissage un événement organisé ce
jeudi à la mairie de versailles selon
les organisateurs 500 offres de contrats
de professionnalisation été présenté aux
étudiants
on a des retours positifs de certains
gènes qui nous disent voilà que qui bat
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas ce centre de
formation où cette entreprise
donc ça amène des solutions à un public
qui est des fois et en demander aussi
perdu parce qu'ils sont jeunes
on a tendance à l'oublier pour ce
rendez-vous 30 organismes de formation
en apprentissage étaient présents pour
orienter plus de 500 jeunes
ça permet
de répondre aux besoins des jeunes de
présenter notre école notre formation
après mes collègues récupère les
contacts et on les suit on appelle les
jeunes et on leur propose un contrat
d'apprentissage ou bien on leur propose
la rentrée pour cette année pour l'année
prochaine c'est une très très bonne idée
surtout à versailles un endroit plutôt
facile à trouver avec des intervenants
très intéressant c'est relativement
productif on ressort avec toutes les
réponses aux questions qu'on aurait pu
avoir et il nous parle il entame le
dialogue directement
une cherche pas ici de chercher ce qu'on
cherche nous découvrir un petit peu et
nous un peu comment qu'en marchant
l'entreprise et voir ça nous intéresse
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine en attendant
les missions locales pôle emploi peuvent
également orienter les jeunes à trouver
un contrat de professionnalisation